here's a question for you why were all
of the pioneers of the Scientific
Revolution Christians of one sort or
another
Catholics Protestants occasionally a
heretic but they all believed in God
Jesus and the Bible so why were all of
the important figures in the Scientific
Revolution from Copernicus all the way
to Newton why were they all
bible-believing theists
coincidence
is what stupid people think but super
smart people like Dr Jordan Peterson
take a closer look at the connection
between the Bible and the Scientific
Revolution as Dr Peterson does in his
recent documentary Lagos and literacy
which explores the history and impact of
the Bible so I hope you enjoy this tour
through the history of the world's most
significant book it's good that
someone's investigating this because the
world seems to have forgotten now if you
don't know what the connection between
Christianity and the Scientific
Revolution is it's good you clicked on
this video because this will be a crash
course on History philosophy Theology
and obviously science and by the end of
this video you'll be one of the elite
few who knows something extremely
valuable and beautiful that was once
appreciated and celebrated by many but
was suddenly lost buried and forgotten
like the Ark of the Covenant
if I may be so bold you're about to be
closer to God even if you're an atheist
so let's go full Indiana Jones climb
down into The snake-infested Well of
Souls and take back what was lost
spoiler alert all of the pioneers of the
Scientific Revolution being Christians
not a coincidence if you want an actual
coincidence let me give you one that
will help introduce the topic a couple
months ago my scheduled reading for a
certain Friday was Romans 1 through 3 in
the Bible an article titled on science
and culture by J Robert Oppenheimer the
father of the atomic bomb and Chapter 3
of Francis Schaefer's short book Escape
from reason
watch how this ended up connecting to
Peterson's documentary and then we'll
watch some clips from the documentary
if you've read Paul's letter to the
Romans you might be familiar with this
passage in chapter one
the wrath of God is being revealed from
Heaven against all the godlessness and
wickedness of people who suppress the
truth by their wickedness since what may
be known about God is plain to them
because God has made it plain to them
for since the creation of the world
God's invisible qualities his eternal
power and divine nature have been
clearly seen being understood from what
has been made so that people are without
excuse
so since the creation of the world God's
invisible qualities his eternal power
and divine nature have been clearly seen
being understood from what has been made
effects tell us something about their
causes the created World tells us
something about the Creator what can be
known about God through nature is clear
enough that people are without excuse
when they reject it
well if the knowledge of God is so clear
that people are without excuse when they
reject it why do so many people reject
it how can they deny the obvious
according to Paul they suppress the
truth more on this shortly
so that was Romans 1 which I had already
read a bunch of times then I read an
explosive article by the father of the
atomic bomb this was new Oppenheimer was
not a Christian he was raised as a
secular Jew later in life he became
interested in a variety of religions
including Eastern religions but in his
article on science and culture he
included a short passage about why he
thought the scientific age began when it
did he wrote it took an idea of progress
which has more to do with the Human
Condition which is well expressed by the
second half of the famous Christian
dichotomy faith and works the notion
that the betterment of man's condition
his civility had meaning that we all had
a responsibility to it a duty to it and
to man I think that it was when this
basic idea of man's condition which
supplements the otherworldly aspects of
religion was fortified and fructose
between the 13th and 15th centuries by
the rediscovery of the ancient worlds
scientists philosophers and
mathematicians that there was the
beginning of the scientific age
so oppenheimer's theory was that there's
some sort of drive for human progress
built into Christianity The Works side
of faith and works Christians found it
meaningful to improve man's condition
Christians therefore took previous
discoveries in science and philosophy
and Mathematics and used them to make
the world a better place
our atomic bomb building friend was
partly right but he didn't come close to
explaining the Scientific Revolution
there's more to science than good
intentions they don't call it a
revolution for nothing
Francis Schaefer got a bit closer in
chapter three of Schaefer's escape from
reason he said
further many of the early scientists had
the same general Outlook as that of
Francis Bacon
1561-1626 wow a guy named Francis
quoting another guy named Francis who
said in Noam or ganam scientiaram Man by
the Fall fell at the same time from his
state of innocence and from his dominion
over nature both of these losses however
can even in this life be in some part
repaired the former by religion and
Faith the latter by the Arts and
Sciences
Francis Bacon was a philosophical
Pioneer of the Scientific Revolution
he's sometimes called the father of
empiricism he promoted what we now call
the scientific method bacon was thinking
in terms of man being created in the
image of God with the capacity to image
God morally and intellectually and by
having dominion over nature but man fell
into sin and lost his innocence and his
Dominion through science man can begin
to restore his dominion over nature so
far this is similar to what Oppenheimer
said we want to make the world a better
place and science can help us do that
but the other Francis Francis Schaefer
continues
therefore science as science and art as
art was understood to be in the best
sense a religious activity
science was a religious activity
notice in the quotation the fact that
Francis Bacon did not see science as
autonomous it's not independent of God
and Revelation for it was placed within
the revelation of the scriptures at the
point of the Fall
yet within that form science and art was
free and of intrinsic value before both
men and God
the early scientists also shared the
Outlook of Christianity in believing
that there is a reasonable God who had
created a reasonable universe and thus
manned by use of his reason could find
out the universe's form
now we're starting to get a more
complete picture the world was created
by a reasonable God so we can understand
the universe by means of reason
these tremendous contributions which we
take for granted we sure do don't we
launched early modern science
it would be a very real question if the
scientists of today who function without
these assurances and motivations would
or could have ever begun modern science
nature had to be freed from the
Byzantine mentality and returned to a
proper biblical emphasis and it was the
biblical mentality which gave birth to
modern science
interesting question could the
scientists of today if they didn't
already know what they know and they
were transported back in time to replace
the Christian pioneers of the Scientific
Revolution could they have begun modern
science
in other words if you didn't already
believe that the Universe had a
reasonable Creator who created a
reasonable universe and that man created
in the image of God can understand the
universe through reason would science
ever get off the ground
you might say yes we would have
eventually figured out things regardless
but if that's what you're thinking you
haven't yet understood how massive this
problem is you're suffering from What's
called the curse of knowledge once you
already know something it's hard to
imagine what it's like not to know it in
our time we already know that the
universe is reasonable in the sense
we're talking about a better word here
is intelligible meaning that it's
fundamental laws can be understood by a
rational agent we've all absorbed the
idea that the Universe can be understood
and the idea that we are the kinds of
beings who are capable of understanding
it so it's difficult to imagine what it
was like for people who didn't have
these ideas
but thanks to history we know something
about the people who didn't have these
ideas
we know they weren't very good at
science
Isaac Newton famously declared if I have
seen further further than the people who
came before me it is by standing on the
shoulders of giants
Newton understood that part of the
reason he was able to figure out so many
things was that people who came before
him put him in that position now what
happens when instead of mocking those
who came before us and patting ourselves
on the back for being so much smarter we
instead think about the Giants on Whose
shoulders we're all standing and we
realize that the Giants themselves are
standing on a foundation of ideas ideas
that provided the foundation for
scientific thinking
doesn't it seem like we might want to
take a closer look at those ideas and
how they're connected to science
back to coincidences the passages we
just looked at were my daily reading for
November 25th the same day that the
trailer for Jordan Peterson's
documentary Lagos and literacy dropped I
watched it that night and there's an
interesting discussion about the
connection between the Bible and the
Scientific Revolution so everything I
read or watched on November 25th was
making some sort of connection between
the Bible and science it was such a cool
coincidence on such an interesting topic
that I decided to make a video about it
here we are Dr Peterson's documentary is
called logos and literacy because much
of it deals with how the Bible spread
literacy and there's an obvious
connection between the spread of
literacy and the spread of Science Why
didn't modern science develop in China
Why didn't it develop in India why did
it develop in Europe and why did these
men come after 16 particularly 17th
century why not in the 15th century
excellent questions that no one ever
bothers to ask this printing of this
book uh
changes everything because it begins an
intellectual Revolution
that now if this is God's word
this has to reform our minds so it's not
just the spread of literacy although
literacy was an essential component
something had to change people's way of
thinking giving rise to an intellectual
Revolution
and today strangely enough we think of
that intellectual Revolution as being
fundamentally opposed to religion
you know one thing that's quite striking
about modern rational culture is this
insistence that the religious tradition
of the West and the scientific tradition
are somehow at fundamental odds the
religious tradition and the scientific
tradition are opposed to one another
this is called the conflict model or the
Warfare model seems to be the dominant
model among internet atheists even
though this model is universally
rejected by actual historians of Science
in other words novices accept it experts
reject it and it used to be Dr
Peterson's View I mean I used to believe
that I think when I was young at least
to some degree
although now I'm very curious about
where that idea came from he used to
believe in the conflict model but he
doesn't know where he got it and that's
because even psychologists are
psychologically conditioned to accept it
but now he's going to go into some
problems with the conflict model because
it's absolutely clear first of all that
the universities themselves emerged out
of the monasteries the university system
was a Christian invention that grew out
of the monasteries Oxford and Cambridge
are monasteries for all intents and
purposes and so the whole university
idea emerged out of the church the
universities grew out of the monasteries
interestingly the methodology of the
universities also grew out of the
methodology of the monasteries Christian
philosophers and theologians trying to
understand passages of scripture would
propose hypotheses and then they would
test their hypotheses they would see how
well their hypotheses fit the evidence
the evidence being what the rest of
scripture said then someone would modify
the hypothesis or come up with a new
hypothesis that fit the evidence better
the idea was that through this process
of hypothesis testing they would keep
getting closer to the truth
what would happen if you absorbed this
method
and you applied it to the universe
hold that thought
and then the notion that the universe is
in fact intelligible and that the
pursuit of truth would be Redemptive
that's a fundamentally religious idea
two completely different points there
one the notion that the universe is
intelligible that it's capable of being
understood by a rational agent is a
religious idea
the pioneers of the Scientific
Revolution believed that the Universe
was created by a cosmic architect who
used mathematical principles to design
the universe
their belief that they could understand
the universe was thus connected to their
belief about who created the universe
that's a religious idea
two The Pursuit Of Truth is Redemptive
it's good notice science can be good for
certain reasons that have nothing to do
with religion someone can use science to
build an air conditioner to keep a room
nice and cool that's good no religion
needed
but what about scientific research and
discovery that doesn't improve our lives
in some way what about learning just for
the sake of learning even if there's no
practical benefit to what you're
learning
that's still good and that part's a
religious idea the Christians of the
Scientific Revolution believed that as
they were learning about the universe
they were learning about God in fact
they regarded science as a form of
worship
the publication of on the Revolutions of
the Heavenly spheres by Nicholas
Copernicus generally marks the beginning
of the Scientific Revolution
look at what Copernicus says about
understanding nature
to know the mighty works of God to
comprehend his wisdom and majesty and
power to appreciate in degree the
wonderful workings of his laws surely
all this must be a pleasing and
acceptable mode of worship to the most
high to whom ignorance cannot be more
gratifying than knowledge
so understanding the universe
makes you better
and then the scientific Endeavor itself
given figures like Newton for example
was embedded inside that religious
tradition the Scientific Revolution is
embedded in the Christian religious
tradition the same religious tradition
that gave rise to the literacy and the
universities and the ideas and the
values that were essential to that
Revolution and yet we're now told that
this religious tradition is in a
Perpetual state of warfare with science
but things weren't always so
111 verse 2. that's the verse which is
written at the entrance of the world's
first scientific laboratory in Cambridge
Cavendish laboratory it says Majestic
are the works of the Lord those who
Delight in them study them
study God's works why it's a form of
worship
in Psalm 19 we read
the heavens declare the glory of God the
skies proclaim the work of his hands day
after day they pour forth speech night
after night they reveal knowledge they
have no speech they use no words no
sound is heard from them yet their voice
goes out into all the Earth their words
to the ends of the world
this idea had already been developing in
Middle Ages which was systematized by
Francis Bacon the father of modern
science Francis Bacon remember him and
he says this is the book of God's words
which is the Bible and the Book of God's
works everything that God has done in
nature so Majestic are the works of the
Lord that we should be reading the works
of God there's the book of God's words
and the Book of God's Works how were
Christians in the monasteries and
universities increasing their
understanding of the book of God's words
they'd come up with a hypothesis then
test the hypothesis against the evidence
then modify the hypothesis or come up
with a better hypothesis
what happened when these Christians
turned to the book of God's works
they used the same method in both cases
there was an external check on their
theories we cannot confine God to our
logic we have to go out and observe what
God has done in his freedom what God has
done in his freedom don't miss this
point
this was the essence of shifting from
the old instrument which is that we can
discover scientific truth through logic
to the modern science of Galileo and
Newton if we didn't go out and
investigate what kind of motion would we
expect from Heavenly objects like
planets
how would we expect them to move
the Ancients would say in perfect
circles a circle was the most perfect
most elegant shape so obviously to them
that's how the Heavenly objects would
move
how do objects of different weights fall
obviously if you double the weight you
double the rate at which something will
fall makes perfect sense in your mind
notice people assumed they could figure
these things out just by thinking about
them
the Christians of the Scientific
Revolution believed that God creates
freely not by some sort of logical
necessity so if you want to know how
God's Universe Works you can't just
think about it you have to go and find
out we don't know even now to what
degree all of those scientific
presuppositions are predicated in
underlying judeo-christian concept
that's true there are a ton of different
factors at work we know that certain
Christian ideas played a huge role but
you could get some of the relevant ideas
from other places for instance
Christians believed that human beings
are created in the image of God and that
this gives us a capacity to understand
the universe but they also believe that
human beings are fallen so it's going to
be a lot of hard work to get things
right
the result was repeated experiments
but if you're coming from an atheistic
naturalistic perspective you could get a
similar result you could say well my
cognitive faculties aren't perfect they
were selected because they gave my
ancestors an advantage in finding food
or a mate they're not really made for
science so if I'm going to use them for
science I'm going to have to be very
careful
either View Christian theism or
naturalism atheistic view that the
natural world is all that exists could
make you think that you should repeat
your experiments
but there are ideas that you get from a
judeo-christian perspective that you
would never get from naturalism because
you have to believe the world has an
intelligible order you have to believe
in the Transcendent object if you're a
scientist or there's nothing to correct
your theories the world is intelligible
think about this if I drop this
clipboard what's it going to do
it's going to fall we all know that
anyone in the ancient world could have
told you that
but more specifically what's it going to
do
it's going to follow a neat little
mathematical equation
look around you
everything is following neat little
mathematical equations
we talk about the laws of nature
but when we talk about the laws of
nature we're using a metaphor and that
metaphor comes from Human governments
the king or whoever's in charge makes a
law and people are supposed to obey the
law but Christians believe in a Divine
King a Divine lawmaker who created
everything and everything obeys his laws
so when I drop the clipboard the
clipboard doesn't just fall it's somehow
obeys a command
why in the name of Common Sense would a
Mindless clipboard obey a command
if you were a naturalist and you didn't
already know that this clipboard no
matter what else it does always follows
equations
would it ever cross your mind that it
follows equations
would you ever bother searching for the
equations that you have no reason to
think are there
no on the contrary if someone came up to
you and claimed that everything around
you is obeying precise mathematical laws
you'd put him in a padded cell because
only a complete lunatic would claim that
a bunch of mindless objects are obeying
the same mathematics that we can figure
out on paper
you know funny thing about mathematics
mathematics is a language
it's the simplest most elegant most
precise language but it's a language
so if everything around us is obeying
neat little mathematical equations all
day every day then we are constantly
surrounded by speech
it's everywhere you can't look in any
direction without being shouted at
Hebrews 1 begins with these words
long ago at many times and in many ways
God spoke to our fathers by the prophets
but in these last days he has spoken to
us by his son whom he appointed the heir
of all things through whom also he
created the world
he is the radiance of the glory of God
and the exact imprint of his nature and
he upholds the universe by the word of
his power
Jesus the son of God is called the Lagos
the word or speech in John 1. the son
the Lagos upholds the universe by the
word of his power Divine speech upholds
the universe
if we want to know what that speech is
what do we do
start studying the universe until we
figure out what God is saying well they
also believe that
investigation
conducted in the spirit of Truth is
Redemptive because every scientist worth
his or her assault is operating under
the presupposition that the honest quest
for truth and Enlightenment is in fact a
good and that's a statement that's an
axiom of Faith it's not just a good it's
worship according to the Christian
pioneers of the Scientific Revolution
scientists who came later absorbed the
same Axiom of Faith even if they didn't
realize where it came from
and all the good scientists that I've
known are possessed by a spirit of Truth
they will allow the world to correct
their erroneous presuppositions and they
do presume that in that Quest is to be
found let's say the betterment of the
individual and Human Society those are
all religious presuppositions as far as
I'm concerned so a collection of ideas
gave rise to the Scientific Revolution
some of those ideas could be held by
different groups for different reasons
but the most important ideas were
religious ideas these ideas could
flourish because of the spread of
literacy and universities
we can even think of the Scientific
Revolution as one big methodical epic
test of these religious ideas the
pioneers of the Scientific Revolution
the Giants on Whose shoulders modern
scientists stand put their religious
ideas to the test
here it might be helpful to draw a
distinction between ordinary scientific
hypotheses and the mother of all
scientific hypotheses the ultimate
scientific hypothesis that started it
all ordinary scientific hypotheses are
tentative claims about the world usually
based on some sort of observation claims
that are confirmed or disconfirmed as
relevant evidence comes in so you notice
that a piece of copper conducts
electricity and you come up with a
scientific hypothesis All Copper
conducts electricity then you test your
hypothesis by getting different pieces
of copper and seeing if they too conduct
electricity you find out that they do
this supports your hypothesis
there are tons of scientific hypotheses
being tested around the globe but all of
these scientific hypotheses are
ultimately derived from the mother of
all scientific hypotheses the mother of
all scientific hypotheses is the
hypothesis on which science as we know
it rests
there are three key elements of the
mother of all scientific hypotheses one
the universe can be understood two we
are the kinds of things that can
understand it and three it's good for us
to understand it if you don't believe
that the universe is at bottom rational
you're not going to spend years of your
life Gathering data to figure out its
laws if you don't believe that human
beings are capable of understanding the
universe why waste your time trying
if you don't believe that it's good to
understand the universe
why would you care
so intelligibility the universe can be
understood capability we can understand
it and desirability we want to
understand it these are the three key
elements of the mother of all scientific
hypotheses and all three have to be in
place for science to get off the ground
in the 21st century we take these three
elements for granted
we believe that the Universe can be
understood and that we're the kinds of
things that can understand it and that
it's good for us to understand it
but there was a time when the vast
majority of people didn't believe these
things
they didn't believe that the Universe
could be understood or that we could
understand it or that it was good to
understand it
and so even though there were some
scientific achievements among the
ancient Greeks and the Egyptians and the
Chinese and the Muslims
there was never anything that would
amount to a revolution in our way of
thinking about the world
the foundational ideas that gave rise to
the Scientific Revolution permeated the
monasteries and universities before the
rise of Science and they were based on
the religious views of the theologians
and philosophers who were advancing
Christian thought
in the 16th and 17th centuries
Christians developed a way of confirming
these foundational ideas scientifically
how do you confirm Christian ideas about
the universe about human beings and
about the intrinsic goodness of
knowledge
by testing lots of ordinary scientific
hypotheses in different fields
every ordinary scientific hypothesis
that's tested whether it's confirmed or
disconfirmed is confirmation of the
mother of all scientific hypotheses
the pioneers of the Scientific
Revolution said in effect
if we're right about the universe and
about ourselves and about the goodness
of knowledge then we'll be able to
figure out physics and chemistry and
biology and so on we were made for this
and every time they tested an ordinary
scientific hypothesis they were
confirming that the Universe can be
understood that we're the kinds of
things that can understand it and that
it's good to understand it
but the set of ideas they were
confirming were religious beliefs and
these ideas are indefensible given
atheistic naturalism
if it still isn't clear why this is a
problem for naturalism let's compare two
hypotheses Christian theism and
naturalism
again we suffer from the curse of
knowledge so we have to try to imagine
what it's like not to know what we know
let's do that by applying What's called
the surprise principle
the universe is intelligible
everything is following a set of laws
the laws are mathematical it's a kind of
speech
how surprising is this assuming that
Christian theism is true
it's not surprising at all it's exactly
what we would expect
but how surprising is it assuming that
naturalism is true
well if the universe wasn't created by a
kind of cosmic architect an ultimate
lawgiver who upholds all of creation by
his speech why in the name of Common
Sense would you expect the universe to
be intelligible a place where everything
is following a set of laws especially
laws that are a form of speech
you would never expect this on
naturalism it makes absolutely no sense
on naturalism
so the intelligibility of the universe
massively favors Christian theism over
naturalism
but even if you have an intelligible
Universe why would you think that we are
the kinds of things that can understand
it
a human being unlike a tree or an insect
or an octopus or a gorilla can figure
out the laws of nature
how surprising is this assuming that
Christian theism is true
it's not surprising at all we're created
in the image of God we were created to
think God's thoughts after him we were
created to have dominion over the
natural world we were literally made for
this sort of thing we were made for
science
how surprising is our ability to
understand the universe assuming that
naturalism is true
it's extremely surprising according to
the only plausible scenario given
naturalism a darwinian scenario our
reasoning ability is the product of
natural selection acting on variations
within a population
natural selection favors traits that
help organisms survive and reproduce so
if human reasoning evolved naturally
it's because it helped our ancestors
survive and reproduce
does this give us any basis for trusting
our reasoning ability when it comes to
questions of theology or philosophy or
science
no our reasoning ability wasn't made for
any of that
at best we could trust our reasoning
ability when it comes to finding berries
or using a spear against an enemy or
doing something to attract a mate
interestingly lest you think I'm somehow
exaggerating Darwin himself noticed this
problem he said
with me the horrid doubt always arises
whether the convictions of man's mind
which has been developed from the mind
of the lower animals are of any value or
at all trustworthy would anyone trust in
the convictions of a monkey's mind if
there are any convictions in such a mind
this is Darwin realizing that the exact
same process that gave rise to his mind
also gave rise to a monkey's mind
would we trust a monkey's mind to figure
out how the universe works no its mind
wasn't made for anything close to that
but a human mind wasn't made for
anything close to that either
so the fact that we're capable of
understanding the universe massively
favors Christian theism over naturalism
what about the intrinsic goodness of
understanding the universe even if
there's no practical benefit to some of
this knowledge
the intrinsic goodness of knowledge is
in a different category of evidence
because goodness isn't something you
find with a telescope or a microscope
saying that understanding the universe
is intrinsically good is a value-based
claim but it's a claim that we all seem
to agree on it's a claim that scientists
take for granted it's a claim that's
foundational to science it's a claim
that makes perfect sense given Christian
theism where understanding the universe
parallels understanding scripture and
it's a claim that makes zero sense given
naturalism
if understanding the universe doesn't
help you survive or reproduce if it
doesn't help you propagate your DNA how
can we say given naturalism that it's
good in any meaningful way
and yet scientists around the world even
the scientists who are naturalists are
driven by the idea that understanding
the universe is intrinsically good
intelligibility capability desirability
if you still don't get how strange these
ideas are given naturalism it's because
you've been christianized
Christian ideas have become so dominant
in your mind that you think they're your
ideas even if you're not a Christian
but if you've absorbed these ideas and
you're not a Christian
it seems you're a heretical Christian
and not really an atheist
and so there are only two kinds of
scientists Christians and heretical
Christians same as during the Scientific
Revolution
how do so many people reject and mock
Christianity even after their thinking
has been thoroughly christianized
remember what Paul said they suppress
the truth
among all our other abilities human
beings have the ability to know that
something is true but to suppress it to
such an extent that we reject it and
mock it
now back to the mother of all scientific
hypotheses the pioneers of the
Scientific Revolution treated their
ideas like one giant hypothesis
if we're right about what the universe
is and about what we are and about the
value of knowledge then we'll be able to
figure this out
and they were right notice every time we
confirm or disconfirm a scientific
hypothesis it's further confirmation of
that original hypothesis the mother of
all scientific hypotheses when you
confirm or disconfirm a scientific
hypothesis you're providing further
confirmation that the universe is
intelligible that we're the kinds of
things that were made to understand it
and so on
every scientific hypothesis that's ever
been tested is confirmation of a set of
ideas that flow directly from Christian
theism
if every scientific hypothesis that's
ever been tested is confirmation of a
set of ideas that flow directly from
Christian theism what can we say
we can say that no hypothesis in history
has more scientific confirmation than
Christian theism
but we can go even further since every
scientific hypothesis that's ever been
tested is confirmation of the mother of
all scientific hypotheses and as we've
seen all three of the key elements of
the mother of all scientific hypotheses
are fundamentally at odds with atheistic
naturalism we can say that every
scientific hypothesis that's ever been
tested is this confirmation of
naturalism
and since every scientific hypothesis
that's ever been tested is
disconfirmation of naturalism it's clear
that no hypothesis in history has more
scientific disconfirmation than
naturalism
the obvious conclusion to draw from all
of this is that if we have any respect
whatsoever for science we must accept
Christian theism and reject atheistic
naturalism
but not so fast there are two reasons
for proceeding with caution here first
we have to be careful when we talk about
evidence confirming something like
Christian theism because Christian
theism includes a lot more than just the
beliefs that God created the universe
and that human beings were created in
God's image and that Understanding God's
creation is a form of worship or
intrinsically good or as Jordan Peterson
said Redemptive
what's been massively confirmed by
science isn't all of Christian theism
but a few particular ideas that flow out
of Christian theism but you get similar
ideas from Judaism and certain forms of
deism and we can come up with more World
Views that include these ideas so what
we can say is that science confirms
something Christian theism-ish
science confirms something that includes
the particular ideas we've been
discussing
the fact remains however
that naturalism has been completely
utterly totally destroyed by science
second and this is something that may
have occurred to you during this video
what happens when the book of God's
words the Bible doesn't seem to line up
with the book of God's works the entire
universe
what happens when the Bible seems to be
telling you one thing and science seems
to be telling you something else
well the dumbest thing you could
possibly do would be to adopt an
ideology that contradicts both scripture
and science so the dumbest thing you
could possibly do would be to adopt
naturalism adopting naturalism would be
extreme suppression of the truth
a much much smarter move would go
something like this
studying the book of God's words led me
to study the book of God's Works
Christian theism led to the Scientific
Revolution I can't just kick the legs
out from under the Giants on Whose
shoulders I'm standing so when there
seems to be a conflict between the book
of God's words and the Book of God's
works I'm going to use the method of the
great minds of the past I'm going to
come up with a hypothesis that explains
why there seems to be a conflict
and I'm going to test that hypothesis
against the evidence
and then I'm going to either revise my
hypothesis or come up with a better one
until I understand the relationship
between the book of God's words and the
Book of God's works my understanding of
both will increase and I will know more
about God
what we want to avoid here is
superficial thinking
tragically today's scientists are
plagued by superficial thinking
as Francis Bacon once put it back when
science was still considered a branch of
philosophy
I dare affirm in knowledge of nature
that a little natural philosophy and the
first entrance into it doth disposed the
opinion to atheism
but on the other side much natural
philosophy and wading deep into it will
bring about men's Minds to religion
wherefore atheism every way seems to be
combined with Folly and ignorance seeing
nothing can be more justly allotted to
the saying of fools than this
there is no God
or as a more recent saying goes
the first gulp from the cup of Natural
Science makes you an atheist
but at the bottom of the cup
God is waiting
[Music]